[Music]
so tell me tell me about how you grew up
kids mom dad brothers and sisters
no brothers and sisters okay only child
yeah
that explains everything go ahead
and
flip it to you
my
dad and stepmom had a little girl when i
was 16. okay and a baby you know 16. so
i did grow up an only child but i have a
half sister now um my mom single mom uh
started a cake shop when i was six
months old to raise and support me
and my dad was not in my life from the
time that i was eight until i was 14.
okay so that drastically shaped me yeah
absolutely uh who i was in high school
in college and then even after that but
i have a great relationship with the now
i found it when i was 14 and we have a
great relationship now um
yeah i mean my parents if you met my
parents my mom and my dad
both so similar
like adventurous spontaneous
entrepreneurial hard work or two like a
fault like don't know when to stop it is
me like it just like oh yeah this
christy makes sense like i'm so i'm so
much like
what i watched
so how do you how do you live with
i see this and i feel what that was and
i experienced what that was and i'm
gonna make
i want this to be different for my kids
and my marriage and my work how do you
balance that
well i think it actually see what i just
did there i didn't mean to say balance
but
how do you how do you
filter that yeah so i think one of the
things that i have always had a very
strong sense of i think strong-willed
children have this i was a strong-willed
child i am a strong-willed adult whether
any grain whatever you want to call it i
have a very strong sense of
ownership
over my life meaning not like
not like in a territorial way but like i
have a strong sense of a right to myself
so like if i'm parenting my children in
some way and someone judges me i'm like
well you got your own kids you do what
you want with your kids like like these
are these are my kids this is my family
so the reason i bring that up is matt
and i have been very intentional
to say what do we want our family to
look like you talk about this like
visualizing plans for the weekend or
whatever
what do we want our family to be about
and
truly my growing up could not have been
more opposite from mats growing up and
both had good qualities but it's almost
like we've come here yeah into the
middle where it's like we're going to
take the good from my side and the good
from his side and the parts we didn't
like from each side and try to not do
those things
um
and just try to just try to be better i
mean i think that's what most
generations try to do try to fix them
um
i think the conflict
initially
was exhausting it can still be but but
initially trying to navigate that and
discern that was really hard like you
y'all did christmas this way and y'all
did house responsibilities this way and
you know i mean
all the communication around that was
exhausting now i think it's more
effortless because we very much are in a
rhythm and we have three kids we've been
doing this a little while we've been
married almost 10 years like we've got a
rhythm of
what we want our family to be about but
i think figuring out what we wanted it
to be about was hard you know because i
don't even know that we knew
like what do you mean
like like when i when we got married
it's like you know in sickness and
health we're like yeah great
[Laughter]
are you ready for kids yeah totally yeah
they're like a dog right but like they
just cry more i don't know no we had no
idea
we had no idea what we were doing we had
no idea you just figured i should go but
um
hard conversations
like we were we were willing well
some of us were willing
some of us got
that didn't love that but i mean we i
mean you know we're different
personality styles he's more an
introvert and extrovert i'm an extrovert
obviously so so what what what when you
look at mom you look at dad and then you
look at you have three little ones
what is one thing you want to make sure
they get that stays on that line
um
i want to say
yes more than i say no
and that's something i good i got for my
mom my mom was a yes mom like it was
like hey let's go get ice cream it you
know yeah like she's a she's an
adventurous mom like she's spontaneous
and i had no rules and i got myself in
debt because i didn't even know how many
works so there's plenty like the
responsible side that was not her sweet
we'll get to the other side yeah yeah
but but she was spontaneous and fun it
was like live like it was like live like
like like live every moment she just has
the zest for life i want my kids to have
that so so in my is that hard for an
eight
no that's very i'm eight wings no i'm
like i'm not all in okay oh yeah so like
when my son says um
i don't know i'm probably gonna get hate
mail from this but that's fine tyler
will filter yeah i'm gonna have to when
i well like i have to get in
when you're driving like when we're
driving down the road in my neighborhood
it's very my in-law is very small safe
neighborhood and my son carter from the
back seat yells can i stick my head out
the sunroof i'm like yeah
right now my default answer as a tired
mom wants me no because i'm tired
because because it's just easier but i'm
trying to find opportunities to say yes
so when he says can we go do this thing
that's that's maybe takes a little more
effort for me yeah but it's me fun to a
six-year-old like for example let's use
a better example when my son wanted to
be
waffle house for halloween not a server
the building yeah absolutely that took
some more effort for me to create this
cardboard building
uh i want to be a mom that says yes and
we made that stinking waffle house and
it was awesome like i just want to be a
mom that says yes i can't always say yes
there's plenty of things i have to say
no to
but when i can say yes i want to say yes
yeah i want his childhood to be fun
memories that if i could do it i tried
to do it what's the reverse of that
what's one thing that stops with christy
and matt
oh well
my mom's gonna listen to this
i think my family doesn't listen to my
show so i'm good i'm psychotic about
being on time
picking him up she was always late to
get me i'd be the last kid picked up
after school just so you know christy
was in the studio today before i was
before everybody was before kelly and
james everybody
christy was here first
uh i wish it translated to everything in
life but there was one day truly carter
was literally two years old in a
preschool and i was gonna be like five
minutes late and i cried the whole way
there like you could just psychoanalyze
that all day but it's like it's like
that is a we will never be late to pick
him up because i don't want him to be
the last one like i just remember that
feeling yeah so
uh there's lists on both sides of all of
it right like we've got good things bad
things oh yeah yeah yeah i'm just always
i'm always interested in what
what people's what drives people toward
what they're running towards and what
they're saying no yeah okay so another
one my mom is creative
super creative entrepreneur she's like
imagine any movie you've ever seen where
there's an inventor like she has patents
like the beauty and the beast the crazy
inventor dad like that's her
so her house was always a mess ah and so
i'm like weird about keeping and i'm not
like monica and friends i'm not like i'm
not one of those people i'm not like a
perfectionist i don't but because i grew
up at a mess it's really important to
have straight house which is extremely
hard with three kids under six so i've
had to like reduce my expectations of
even what's realistic but that is
something that like
it comes from that childhood place
of having a messy house that i that i
wouldn't have friends over i want
friends to be able to stop by and they
can come in
and that yeah that's hard
so on being on time and keeping a mess a
clean place two things
john delaney's not known